[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend das sportliche in der
Sendung übernimmt wieder Christin Otto
sehr gerne in 15 Minuten guten Abend
dann verschaffen wir uns einen
Überblick Panik und Entsetzen in Prag an
einer Universität in der Innenstadt
eröffnet ein bewaffneter das
mindestens 15 Menschen werden getötet
viele weitere
verletzt eine Welt im Untergrund Israels
Armee entdeckt Tiefe in den Tunneln der
Terrororganisation Hamas Fahrstühle
kommandoräume und
Wohnungen Deutschland hustet Deutschland
schnieft die Zahl der akuten
Atemwegserkrankungen schnellt in die
Höhe jeder zehnte ist betroffen oder war
es
gerade
Tschechiens Hauptstadt steht unter
Schock in einem Universitätsgebäude in
Prag hat ein Angreifer am Nachmittag das
Feuer eröffnet mindestens 15 Menschen
sind Tod Dutzende verletzt der Schütze
sei laut Polizei getötet worden die
Schüsse fielen an der Philosophischen
Fakultät der Karlsuniversität in der
Altstadt und ganz in der Nähe so
bekannte Touristenattraktionen wie die
Karlsbrücke Christian Volk berichtet
es ist Nachmittag als in der Innenstadt
von Prag Panik ausbricht nur weg so
schnell es geht zur gleichen Zeit wenige
hundert Meter entfernt ein Angreifer
schießt in der Karlsuniversität um sich
die Studierenden bauen Barrikaden für
einige ist die letzte Rettung das
Fenstersims eine Putzfrau erzählt dem
ZDF wie sie den Angriff erlebt
hat im ganzen Gebäude war Lärm dann sah
ich die Polizei und den ang
fing an mich anzuschreien ich SLE zu ihm
gehen und dann fing die Polizei anz
schreien ich SLE weglaufen und mich
verstecken der Angreifer tötet mehrere
Menschen und verletzt dutzende weitere
die Polizei holt immer wieder
Studierende aus den Gebäuden als der
Angriff passiert ist Patrizia chemus
gerade auf dem nachhausweg ich hatte
sehr beklemmendes Gefühl weil ich auch
nicht wusste was passiert man hörte
überall Sirene man sah viel
Blaulicht ja man merkte so eigentlich
überall von der Karlsbrücke konnte man
sehen dass alle Straßen auf einmal
blockiert waren und es war ja so ganz
gespenstisch laut Polizei ist auch der
mutmaßliche Angreifer unter den Toten
einen Terrorangriff schließen die
Behörden bisher
aus die Tragödie ist tiefgreifend sie
wird folgen haben für die Atmosphäre in
der Universität für die Angehörigen und
die Zeugen dieser tragischen Ereignisse
mit der Tat beschäftigt sich am Abend
auch noch die tschechische Regierung in
einer
Sondersitzung unsere Korrespondentin für
Tschechien Britta hilper ist momentan in
Berlin Britta was ist denn bislang über
die Hintergründe der Tat
bekannt ja ich bin mit meinem Team in
Tschechien in Kontakt und die sagen mir
es sieht sehr danach aus dass es keine
politischen sondern persönliche Motive
waren die den Täter zu dieser
schrecklichen Tat getrieben haben wenn
man von persönlich überhaupt sprechen
kann der Täter scheint tief gestört
gewesen zu sein auf einem telegramkanal
der im Augenblick im Netz kursiert wird
klar dass er einen generellen Hass auf
die Menschen auf die Welt hatte und auch
auf sich selbst und auch hatte die
Absicht hatte sich am Schluss selbst zu
töten es handelt sich wohl um einen
24-jährigen Tschechen einen Studenten
eben dieser Fakultät von dem auch
Kommolitonen sagen er hätte wohl
psychische Probleme gehabt und es ist
auch bekannt dass er mehr Waffenscheine
und Waffe in Waffen in seinem Besitz
hatte der Tag begann dann auch ganz
schrecklich mit einem ersten Mord im
eigenen Haus es scheint als sei der
Vater ihm auch zum Opfer gefallen und
dann hat sich der Täter der Universität
in Prag zugewandt Brita Hilpert vielen
Dank für diese
Information während in Ägypten über eine
erneute Feuerpause verhandelt wird gab
es heute eines der schwersten
Feuergefechte seit Beginn des gasak
Krieges außerdem will Israels Militär
das zentrale Tunnelsystem der Hamas
entdeckt haben im Zentrum von Gaza Stadt
und von dort aus soll es in ein 20 m
unter der Erde gelegenes großes
tunnelnetzwerk gehen henrite demesia
berichtet der Eingang zu einem Tunnel in
Gaza Bilder die das israelische Militär
veröffentlichte sollen ein
weitverzweigtes Tunnelsystem unter der
Stadt Gaza zeigen eigene Wasser und
stromschächte f Stühle Wohnungen in bis
zu 20 m
Tiefe die israelische Armee hat im
Herzen von gazastadt operiert wo sich
eine Terrorbasis der politischen und
militärischen Führung der Hamas in
zivilen Gebäuden befand und dann haben
wir unter diesem Gebiet ein weit
verzweigtes strategisches Netzwerk
gefunden welches der hamask gedient hat
unterdessen gehen die Kämpfe
unvermindert weiter zuletzt hatte es
immer wieder Forderungen nach einer
erneuten Feuerpause gegeben auch um
weitere Geiseln zu
befreien israel hat auch heute noch
einmal sehr deutlich zum Ausdruck
gebracht dass es eine Rückkehr zu einer
Pause und die weitere Freilassung von
Geiseln begrüßen würde das Problem ist
und bleibt die Hamas die USA als eine
der engsten Verbündeten Israels haben
immer wieder zur Mäßigung und zum Schutz
der Zivilbevölkerung aufgefordert die
Reaktion von Ministerpräsident netanu
gewohnt
kompromisslos wir käp bis zum Sieg wir
werden diesen Krieg nicht stoppen bis
alle unsere Ziele erreicht sind die
vollständige Eliminierung der Hamas und
die Freilassung aller unserer Geiseln
und nach der Eliminierung der Hamas
werde ich alles daran setzen dass Gaza
keine Bedrohung mehr für Israel
darstellt und so sind die von der
israelischen Armee entdeckten Tunnel
eine weitere Nachricht eine Fußnote in
einem Krieg der bereits 76 Tage
dauert jetzt zu unseren Nachbarn nach
Polen dort gibt es ja eine neue
politische Führung und schon die ersten
Tage der proeuropäischen Regierung unter
Donald Tusk haben es in sich denn Polens
Parlament hat entschieden den
umstrittenen Umbau der Justiz durch die
abgelöste nationalonservative
peaceregierung rückgängig zu machen
außerdem wurde die komplette Spitze der
ehemals öffentlichrechtlichen Fernseh
und Radiosender gefeuert sie hätten in
den vergangenen Jahren Propaganda der
peace parartei verbreitet über die vol
rückwärts in Polen Natalie
Steger es ist durchaus grotesk statt
News auf dem Nachrichtenkanal TVP Info
läuft heute das noch hat die neue
senderspitze nicht alles zusammen für
den Neustart eine vorabbotschaft eines
neuen
Moderators das Bild was hier A8 Jahre
lang mit genau ausgesuchten Farben
gemalt wurde ich versichere es ihnen
endet nun anstelle von einer
propagandasuppe wollen wir sauberes
Wasser anbieten
die neue Führungsriege will objektiv
berichten die alte wurde entlassen
bizarrezenen in der Nacht Abgeordnete
der abgewählten peace wollen den Sender
besetzen auch parteichf Kinski verbringt
zuletzt eine Nacht bei TVP die
Nationalkonservativen inszenieren sich
als Verteidiger der vermeintlich freien
Medien auch der Staatspräsident ein man
der
peace
und diese nach der Meinung des
Kulturministers Gesetze
ersetzen die neue proeuropäische
Regierung unter Donald Tusk hat es eilig
mit vorab parlamentsbeschlüssen
großflächiger medienrückbau dazu das
gleiche parallel bei der Justiz das mag
radikal wirken doch die neue polnische
Regierung kehrt schlicht in die
forpacezeit zurück und tut damit genau
das was internationale unabhängige
Institutionen und auch Brüssel längst
von Polen erwarten TVP in den letzten
Jahren nicht mehr öffentlich rechtlich
sondern staatliches sprachhor um 19:30
Uhr sollen die neuen Nachrichten auf
Sendung
gehen
bundesinnenministerin fäer waren von
neuen Krawallen in Deutschland die durch
den Gazakrieg und proalästinensische
Demonstrationen zu Silvester angeheizt
werden könnten sie habe die Sorge vor
blinder Wut und sinnloser Gewalt z.B
gegen Polizisten und Rettungskräfte
sagte fäer dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland letztes Jahr an Silvester
gab es in mehreren Städten Ausschreitung
bei denen Einsatzkräfte massiv
angegriffen
wurden wir alle erleben das gerade um
uns herum geschniee und gehuste akute
Atemwegserkrankungen breiten sich immer
mehr aus seit Wochen steigen die Zahlen
stark das Robert Koch Institut rechnet
aktuell mit 8,9 Millionen Betroffenen
weit verbreitet sind im Moment RSV
Infektionen Corona und Erkältung
gleichzeitig nehmen jetzt die
Grippefälle schnell zu mehr erfahren wir
von Peter
Aumeier die hausärztliche
Gemeinschaftspraxis Martins Ried bei
München heute am frühen Morgen noch ist
es ruhig aber dies wird nicht so
bleiben ich ma mir tatsächlich etwas
Sorgen wenn die Belastung so weitergeht
dann wird es sicherlich für die Praxen
schwer werden der jetzt influenzwelle
der rs-welle den coronawelle und auch
auch den angsten anderen Krankheiten
Keuchhusten Lungenentzündung
entsprechend her zu werden rund jeder
ZTE in Deutschland hat momentan Husten
Schnupfen oder andere Erkältungssymptome
man merkt schon im BEKANNTEN Kreis ist
relativ oft jemand krank oder mehrere
Personen gleichzeitig mit meinem
ladenkunden ich würde sagen zwei Drittel
alle infiziert es ist extrem Grund für
den hohen Stand an akuten
atemwichserkrankungen sind ganz
verschiedene Infektionserreger allen
voran rsven Erkältungsviren an denen vor
allem kindererk mit 20% Corona mit 19%
Anteil renovieren also grippale Infekte
mit 18% und Influenza also Grippe
auffallen gestiegen mit 17%. alle diese
Infektionserreger nehmen momentan noch
zu vor Weihnachten ist die Aktivität der
akuten Atemwegsinfekte einfach sehr hoch
typischerweise geht es dann über die
Weihnachtstage wenn man eben wenn die
Schulen zu sind wenn nicht so viele
Menschen arbeiten gehen wenn man mehr
separate in den Familien ist erstmal
zurück und steigt dann im Januar wieder
an in der Gemeinschaftspraxis Martins
Ried stellt man sich dennoch erstmal auf
mehr Arbeit
ein nie zuvor gab es Zugang zu so viel
Informationen wie heute gleichzeitig
gilt nie zuvor war es schwieriger zu
erkennen welche Informationen wirklich
wahr sind und welche nicht Stichwort
Fake News und künstliche Intelligenz der
richtige Umgang mit unterschiedlich
informationquellen und Medien ist vor
allem auch eine extreme Herausforderung
an Schulen über einen Ansatz der helfen
könnte berichtet jetzt Petra
Otto Instagram Youtube tiktok sie sind
unterwegs in den sozialen Netzwerken
alle jeden Tag wer meint weniger als
eine Stunde geht rüber weniger als eine
Stunde es sind eher drei bis vier und
mehr an diesem technischen Gymnasium
Social Media beste Unterhaltung und oft
einzige Informationsquelle in Social
Media ist es so dass du oft Meinungen
und Aussagen hörst die wo wahrscheinlich
eher in die falsche Richtung gehen oder
nicht stimmen man untersucht jetzt nicht
von wo es kommt wer es geschrieben hat
man glaubt halt einfach Medienkompetenz
zu vermitteln ist Schulaufgabe doch die
Schulen kommen bei Social Media kaum
hinterher man bräuchte da Stunden die
wirklich nur
Medienkompetenz Schulen das können wir
so als Gemeinschaftskunde Lehrer oder
allgemeinbildende Lehrer gar nicht alles
auffangen nicht alle Leisten sich wie
die Esslinger Friedrich Ebert Schule so
ein Workshop wie erkenne ich Fake News
lernen Sie hier die Herkunft von Bildern
verifizieren und sie sollen verstehen
wie ein Profil erstellt wird aufgrund
ihrer Nutzungsgewohnheiten und sie
dadurch Werbung erhalten und auch
gefilterte politische Beiträge unser
Ziel ist Jugendlichen zu helfen sich
eine kritische Meinung zu bilden Quellen
kritisch einzuschätzen und sich gegen
Extremismus zu wappnen und Schulen darin
zu unterstützen mit der bazard App
politische Bildung voranzutreiben
die App die die beiden entwickelt haben
vergleicht unterschiedliche Quellen zu
aktuellen Themen Pro und Kontra
Palästinenser Demo solche Diskussionen
im Lehrplan Stiefkinder aber mehr
Medienkompetenz wäre genauso wichtig wie
neue turnallen oder
Tablets als vor drei Tagen auf Island
aus einer Kilometer langangen Spalte
plötzlich die Lava schoss ist man noch
von einem längeren vulkanusbruch
ausgegangen aber die Aktivität des hat
schnell und deutlich nachgelassen für
Entwarnung ist es allerdings noch zu
früh und die Menschen im Südwesten
Islands stellen sich auf eine unruhige
Weihnachtszeit ein zu hat kaldi
berichtet es sind faszinierende Bilder
voller Urgewalt und wilder Schönheit die
Erde im Südwesten Islands spuckt weiter
Lava und Asche es ist Tag 3 nach dem
Ausbruch die Eruption hat an Kraft
verloren die hat abgenommen und
entsprechend gibt es auch weniger
giftige
Gase von der Aufregung bekommt der
kleine SW nichts mit die Familie musste
jetzt zu Hause in grinderwig überstürzt
verlassen jetzt leben sie vorübergehend
in der
Hauptstadt natürlich möchte man gerne
zurück aber die Angst die Ungewissheit
auch wenn es momentan vorbeint man weiß
ja nie was noch
kommt den Bau von Schutzbarrieren haben
sie bereits vor Wochen begonnen um die
Orte und ein Kraftwerk vor der Lava zu
schützen ist es vorbei wird es morgen
oder in einer Woche vorbei sein oder ist
mit einem erneuten größeren Ausbruch zu
rechnen sie können nur hoffen dass sich
der Lavastrom weiter verlangsamt abkühlt
und
aufhört kein Vulkan bei uns aber es hat
sich was zusammengebraut über
Deutschland das Sturmtief solltan es
bringt schwere Böhen und viel Regen mit
und hat schon in mehreren Bundesländern
Schäden angerichtet besonders betroffen
die Küstengebiete ab dem späten Abend
droht dann der Nordsee eine schwere
Sturmflut außerdem sind starke
Niederschläge und Überschwemmungen
möglich wie hier in Niedersachsen der
Sturm hat schon zahlreiche Bäume
umgerissen im Großraum Hamburg fielen
deshalb mehrere Zugverbindungen
aus so in der Fußball buundesliga geht's
ja in die Weihnachtspause und die ist
für Bayer
23 sei unvergesslich sagen sie die Bayer
11 kann als Spitzenreiter die Auszeit
genießen und er freut sich auch noch an
einem Rekord seit Saisonstart 25
Pflichtspiele nacheinander nicht
verloren besser als der HSV vor gut 40
Jahren großartig auch das 4:0 gegen
Bochum was für eine vorweihnachtsgala
von Leverkusen mit einem Hattrick von
Patrick schick in dieser Mannschaft ist
relativ einfach machen träumen ist
erlaubt es ist historisch was an diesem
Abend in Leverkusen gegen bochenem
passiert 2:0 nach 32 Minuten durch
schick der zu alter Form langsam
zurückfindet natürlich ich war immer
Stürmer wel ich hat t geschossen das ist
meine Arbeit zum 25 Mal nacheinander
bleibt Leverkusen ohne Niederlage das
hat noch kein bundeslig ist geschafft
nicht mal die Bayern schickt zum dritten
vor der Pause das 3:0 W wir haben das
erreicht das dann ist das Besondere
vorne Spiel ich h sein ich habe nicht
gedacht das Bonny face spät
eingewechselt veredelt das 4:0 der
scheinbar unbesiegbaren in dieser Saison
mit ihrem so ruhigen Trainer
Alonso apropos ruhig Ruhe kehrt vorerst
in Dortmund ein nachdem sich der BVB
nach mehrstündigen Gesprächen für die
Fortsetzung der Zusammenarbeit mit
Trainer Edin tersit entschieden hat
trotz der sportlichen Rückschläge der
erste fC Köln hat dagegen am Tag nach
dem 0:2 bei Union Berlin die Trennung
von Trainer Steffen Baumgart bekannt
gegeben es sei ein gemeinsamer
Entschluss 10 Tore und 10 Punkte in 16
Spielen sowie der vorletzte
Tabellenplatz das ist zu wenig fünf
Neulinge hat handballbundestrainer
Alfred geslerson für die EM in
Deutschland ab 10 Januar Berufen neben
4u21 Weltmeistern auch Rückraumspieler
Martin Hanne von Hannover Burgdorf der
noch nie ein Länderspiel bestritten hat
der Europäische Gerichtshof ermöglicht
per Urteil die Gründung einer
fußballsleague gegen den Willen der
Verbände die wie die UEFA und FIFA ihre
Position nicht missbrauchen dürfen
andere Wettbewerbe dürfen nicht verboten
werden das Urteil des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs es ist ein Paukenschlag für
den bisher organisierten Clubfußball und
öffnet die Tür für eine
Superleague denn es widerspreche
europäischenem Wettbewerbsrecht wenn
große Fußballverbände wie FIFA und UEFA
ihre Monopolstellung für
fußballwettbewerbe ausnutze und anderen
das Gründen einer Liga untersage die
UEFA reagiert gelassen weiß viele
europäische Länder hinter sich sieht die
Unterstützung der Superleague aktuell
nur durch spanische Vereine die deutsche
fußballiga DFL stützt das europäische
Sportmodell explizit und lehnt
Wettbewerbe außerhalb der von den
Verbänden und liegenorganisierten
Wettbewerbe ab und auch Bayern München
winkt ab die Bundesliga bildet das
Fundament des FC Bayern ebenso stehen
wir zu den europäischen clubwettbewerben
unter dem Dach der UEFA und Dortmunds
Clubchef Watzke bekräftigt dass der BVB
für eine Superleague nicht zur Verfügung
steht und ich habe noch fix einen
Hinweis Chi alpin slalum Frauen in
kurscheew zweiter Lauf 20:45 Uhr bei uns
im Livestream sportstudio.de Lena D ist
allerdings schon raus blöd dann vielen
Dank Christin ich habe nachgerechnet
noch dreimal schlafen bis Heiligabend
wer noch nicht in Stimmung sein sollte
ist es vielleicht gleich nach den
Klängen des weltberühmten dresner
kreuzkors und anderen Sängerinnen und
Sängern die gerade im dresner
dynamoostadion gesungen haben beim
großen Adventskonzert mit rund 25 000
Menschen und das bei Sturm und
[Musik]
Regen das kenne auch ich und es klingt
nach einer gelungenen
Einstimmung ja das Wetter schwierig fast
in ganz Deutschland warnt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor Sturm und Dauerregen
mehr dazu gleich von östen terli um
21:45 Uhr empfehle ich ihn das heute
journal mit Donja Hayali morgen an
dieser Stelle Jana pareiges ich wünsche
Ihnen schon mal schöne und stressfreie
Weihnachten und jetzt erstmal einen
entspannten Abend auf
[Musik]
bald
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter nun ist sie da die
sturmlage aber es ist nicht nur der Wind
sondern auch Regen und Schnee bis morgen
Abend bekommen wir es mit weiteren Regen
und sogar Schneefällen bis ins Flachland
zu tun allerdings bleibt der Schnee
nicht liegen die detaillierten
Windverhältnisse ja ganz im Norden sehr
viel Wind hier am Abend noch gut 120 km
pro Stunde möglich in Böhen an der
Nordsee noch mehr 130 eventuell auch
noch da drüber an der Ostsee ja und im
Flachland sind es 60 bis 100 km pro
Stunde in den Berglagen natürlich noch
da drüber und in der Nacht gibt es dazu
Regen das Ganze zieht allmählich
südwärts es ist auch Dauerregen dabei
ansonsten über den Wind haben wir ja
gerade schon gesprochen viel Wind an der
Ostsee bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 8°
im Südwesten und 1° im fogtland und
morgen weiterer Regen und Schauer vor
allem im Norden die ziehen durch und
dann kommt neuer Regen auf ja und der
kan er gibi sein und sehr viel Wind zum
Nachmittag dann im Südosten Temperaturen
dazu bis 11° im Südwesten die nächsten
Tage am Samstag immer noch Sturm und
Dauerregen bei 2 bis 10° und auch Heilig
Abend ziemlich ungemütlich schönen
Abend